foreign
today we will take you through the heads
of lab demo of how you can predict
percentage using python before we start
I hope this screen is clearly visible
and the audio is fine if yes please type
in here if there are any issues do let
us know in the chat section so that we
can resolve them
I'm repeating again before we start I
hope the skin is clearly visible and the
audio is fine if yes please type in yes
if there are any issues do let us know
in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
wait for some more minutes to let other
people join
let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on multiple Technologies
if you are a tech geek on a continuous
hunt for the latest technological Trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
Lord
I'm repeating again let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
Technologies
if you are a tech geek on a continuous
hunt for the latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribe to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn
right I think we can get started so in
today's session we will go through
Myers-Briggs Personality prediction
after that a hands-off lab demo of how
to predict the person personality using
Python and machine learning
we will perform different function and
different python libraries
so before we move on to the programming
part let's first discuss what is
Myers-Briggs Personality prediction and
proceed further for the same
so what is Myers break personality
prediction
to better understand personality
characteristics in the broader
population the mbti examination was
created although there is no such thing
as Better or Worse personality prevents
the MBT examination can Aid individuals
in understanding their strength weakness
and potential difference from the others
so there are some types of mbti
indicators
there is no best or better personality
type than another
it is not a device made to search for
abnormalities and dysfunction
it is sole purpose is to assist you in
discovering more about yourself
so there are four separate skills make
up the actual questionnaire
first is
extrovert and introversion second is
sensing and intuition
third is thinking and feeling
for this judging and perceiving
So based in these four there are some
types so there are 16 types
istj istp isfj isfp isfj like this ENFP
e and FJ entp and entg
so what is meaning of isdj
I means introversion s means sensing t
means thinking and J means judging like
this
so dear Learners if you want to upskill
your AI and machine learning skills so
give yourself a chance to Simply learn a
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning which comes with
completion certificate and in-depth
knowledge of AI and machine learning
check this course detail from the
description box below
so now let's move to our programming
part
so first we will open command prompt
first we will open command prompt so
here I will add Jupiter
enter
so this is landing page of Jupiter
notebook so here I will go new
python file
so this is how the python kernels look
like
so here I will change name
B minus big personality prediction
okay
so at first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
analyzing the data
so here I will write
lab
report Rd
or numpy as NP
important
pandas as speedy
port matplotlib
Pi plot
as PLT
T-Bone
SNS
then port
broadly
dot offline
and
okay
then here import
antly
dot graph
and this
vgs object as good
I'll import
currently
dot tools
as TLS
from
bs4
import
ant
then here I will write from SK learn dot
model
underscore selection
port
because underscore validate
okay
then again let me copy from here
till import
then here I will import straight
ified
so
yes so here I will import sqlarn
dot lenient
or model
port
logistic regression
so from this
we'll write here SK learn
okay
done
dot model underscore selection
code
to learn
Dot
fourth
is
okay so here I will write more from
learn dot decomposition
board
truncated
yeah
so here I will write from
SK learn
Dot
here
underscore
protection
text
import
okay
then from SQ learn
dot pipeline
Port pipeline
from let's kill on
dot is
multinomial
binomial NB
and
p y Dot
in it
underscore
connected
is equals to
buy the python Library used for working
with array it also has a function for
working with domain of lineal algebra
and matrices it is open source project
and you can use it freely numpy stand
for numerical python so panda is the
software Library written for the pandas
programming language
for data manipulation and Analysis in
particular it offers data section and
operation for manipulating numerical
tables and Time series
the open source python Library based on
matplotlib is called seabo it is
utilized for data exploration and data
visualization with data frames and the
pandas Library c bond function with
these
matplotlib for Python and its numerical
extension numpy matplotlip is a cross
platform data visualization and
graphical charting project
as a result it presents a strong open
source substitute for Matlab the api's
format plotlib allows programmers to
incorporate graphs into GI application
Beautiful soap python software called
Beautiful soup is called parse HTML and
XML text
for process Pages it generates a pass
tree that can be used to extract HTML
data for web scripting
pipeline the pipeline goal is to put
together several phases that can be
cross validate while using different
parameters
so moving forward let's import some
different data that you can download
these data set from the description box
below so here I will write train
equals to PD Dot
it underscore CSV
and then here
PTI
one
Dot
and second one is
equals to
PD Dot
treat
underscore
users
let's see
okay
then there is one more
equals to
PD Dot
p
SV
that
forum
suggests
so here I will write mbti
question
I
say the key value
so I'm writing a keyword
version
come on
then okay
next version
it
contributions
uh
capital
one
e then t means thinking
f means
healing
J means
judging
loading
so it's still loading for data set
three different data set mbti1 cfp users
and Forum messages you can download
these data set from the description box
below
or you can find this link
for the Drive Link
so these are like large data sets so it
will take time sometime
importing is data says done so
let's use shape function to see how many
rows columns are present in train data
set so here I will write train
dot shape
as you can see 865 8675 rows at two
columns
okay so let's move forward
so we're to take a class
repeat
so we take a look to classes so it look
like very unbalanced data set so here I
will write CNT
dot dot answer equals to
train
type
value counts
so here I will plot dot figure
guys
let's do
12 comma four
to
sns.bar plot
ENT
that is
dot values
to 0.8
of plot dot y label
experiences
size
table
types different types then font size
13
LT dot show
okay
so here you can as you can see different
types of Personality infj infj INTP intj
so on okay
so these are number of occurrence and
the types
so moving forward let's group user ID
and messages so I will write here
visual
yeah so here I will write PS
message
uh fill any
yes
Dot
underscore join
equals to PS dot Group by
post
right
message
Dot
create here I will write
all
join
hello
that
loading
moving forward let's check accuracy with
different classifiers and models
so first we will check with extra tree
classifier okay
so for that
right here like e g extra tree
classifier equals to
increase
[Music]
classifier
then underscore
estimators
equals to 20
comma Max
plus 2 4
equals to
minus
so here I will write TF IDF
question
let me copy it from here
and
[Music]
underscore range
issue
comma one
yeah
upwards
SVD
it was
located
opponent
does
first two
pipeline
PF
I
d f i
the right here
that
foreign
I am doing because of spelling mistakes
and the kind of bits
is to Pi
Shuffle
and here I will write NP Dot
okay sorry
NP dot random
dot read
ing
soup
Tracy
vlog
so
please
in
Dennis type
the red scoring
good morning
dots equals to minus n
it is still loading
okay
now we will print so here I will write
print
TV
done 0.4
f
and I will write
plus minus
hold on
0.4 f
B Dot
mean
result
the
position
results
copy at all and the chip
accordingly
so now F1 score whatever score we will
write here F1
same
okay
then here here right NP dot mean
accuracy
here you will write test F1
underscore
micro
okay
then same yeah
test
F1
and
for the negative laws
right
law
good
here I will write negative
in this log underscore loss
if
underscore log
underscore
run it
so
of it let me make it
so here you can see the accuracy and
it's it is not that good with xrt
classifier as the data set is very
unbalanced F1 score is a better metric
than accuracy
so we will check with some alternative
models so let's try if we can find a
more accuracy with model another model
although we haven't got a lot of data
so here I will write TF
clean
next
okay
so here I will write text
equals to
beautiful
ml
three dot sub
the
with it
r
comma
okay then text was to
re Dot so
http
says
button
text
here I will add train
posts
to
train
course Dot
apply
today okay done so let's check accuracy
with first name base okay
oh I'm done with the code because the
code are mostly same so I just copied it
from
my documents okay so let me enter
so here you can see the accuracy is far
better than
this x30 classifier
okay so we will check from one mode we
will let's check for logistic regression
so let me write the code first then I
will get back to you
I'm done with the code let's see the
accuracy of logistic regression
so let me press enter
loading you can see
yeah
so accuracy is far good than the both
so is this model overfitting could we
have a pattern model with more data
let's see the learning curve okay
so here I will write train
underscore sizes
comma train
underscore scores
comma
pursue
running underscore girl
post
and
they
apples
jobs
question
equals to
here right F1 underscore
pane
prices
goes to NP
Dot
base
1 comma one points
no
state
one
and press enter
okay it is K false
this is dispatcher
so for the learning curve it is a long
code
so let me write it for you again it's
still loading
I don't know what
so I'm done with the code so let me run
it
now let's see the Curve
so for that that's that import
or we don't
have that plot learning
I think of
chain
posts
comma train
type
train
and devices
again underscore scores
come on
test
underscore this course
comma one
point
zero
figure size should be
okay so if not 15 15 comma six
okay
elt dot show
here as you can see
training school cross validation Score
Learning graph
so it's look like that with more data
the more model gets better and better so
that is not overfitting
so what we will do
so moving forward let's see kaggle user
personality let's apply our model to
whole kaggle user commands let's see
what is the most common kaggle user
personality
so for that I will write here PS
underscore join
then
comments
equals to
this underscore join
message
Dot
apply
text
that I will let model
underscore learning dot fit
train
posts
train
type
all equals to model
it
join
it's loading here
so moving forward what we what we will
do let's create a bar graph to see
kaggle user personality okay
loading
it will show the warning something like
let me write the code for the paragraph
okay it's a long code so I will write
first then I will get back to you
oh I wrote the code so let me run it and
see the personality
so here you can see e s f p is the most
used personality
so let's see the count personality count
percentage count for that I will write
here
let's go
DF
percent
to
depiction underscore TF
count
and underscore DF then again count
where I will add prediction underscore
DF
description
personality
X
joint
PTI
right one
test
so here you can see the percentage count
for every personality
okay with description extraordin sense
and feeling perceiving ESF
so
finally at the end we will see the
personality distribution using pie chart
okay so here I will write labels equals
to prediction
underscore TF
I will write description
yeah
sizes
equals to prediction underscore DF
tent
is equals to go
Dot I
equals
to labels
comma
values
first two sizes
a out should be
layout equals to go
Dot layout
pattern
plus two
okay
user
personalities
data
equals to
Trace
that
and people
Dot
then
data also data
divide Dot
I plot
okay let me turn it
let me run it
so here you can see the pie chart
so like most fifty percent is e s f p
okay then 23 is introversion institution
then
so on okay so every thing is written
here adding every color
so apparently the most common calculator
user personality is esfp this is 50.6
percent okay
so extroversion sensing feeling
perceiving but we are getting this
conclusion based on users command it is
reasonable to think that user who
participate more writing comments are
more extrovert our sample data don't
come from the kaggle users population it
is only based on the comments
it comes from the Kegel users command so
our conclusion can't be applied to all
kaggle users
so like more accuracy models could be
obtained the more data
I hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any good doubt
you can ask in the comment section below
our team will respond to you shortly
I hope you must have understood how you
can do
the personality prediction using Python
and machine learning if you have any
queries you can ask in the comment
section below our team will shortly
provide you the correct solution or if
you want this full code you can comment
for the same thank you so much for being
here if you enjoyed this video please do
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
give like to this video thank you and
keep learning
foreign
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here